I sent you earlier on a video about Dove
so for the people that haven't seen it
Dove is on a mission to challenge and
change female representation in video
games and help make gaming a positive
space for women and girls so they've
created this video of girl superhero and
she slays this evil Baddie and then she
gets back into the changing room and
takes her armor off and gains 80 pounds
yeah immediately and then like sits down
and realizes I don't need to wear the
armor that is holding me in and then she
goes out and keeps on fighting but now
she's 80 pounds bigger female characters
in games do not accurately represent the
diverse Gamers of the world and are
often heavily placed and created within
narrow unrealistic beauty standards 74
of girls feel unrepresented in video
games there was no soap in their
commercial
I get it I'm all about helping women and
having them being represented it's
getting hacky now like Miller Lite Bud
Light Starbucks had a big commercial
with the Trans well now it's just hacked
the whole thing with the marketing and
stuff like this like this kind of art
you gotta goat a new way isn't that the
whole point of being original when they
Zig you zag